Have you,
have you ever been working up to the deadline where you've been working on the
show and it's, it's been airing.
[Inaudible] Oh.
Sinkers, uh, season three. I was doing my Ginga, so yeah,
again guides a second step of the animation and, uh.
What does getting go involve? Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Kinda knows nothing about salvation. So we're going to break it down.
For now. Our explains the process of the fabrication of Ganga. Okay.
So you have the County mentor me. Um, um,
I received an offer of work by Twitter or by mail or Twitter sometimes
free too, because a lot of, uh, assistant production, uh,
looking for animators on Twitter. And so for Japan,
most of the Japanese animator, they use Twitter has a, uh, portfolio,
uh.
Right. Tons of DM, right? Yeah. That makes sense.
And, uh, so hi, uh, I'm uh,
I'm from this to ju I have this project, uh, the schedule is that,
do you want to work on it? So I look my schedule if it's okay.
If it's good match. Yeah, sure. Okay. Let's let's uh, put a,
uh, a date for the meeting, do the meetings. So, okay. This date.
So I go to the schedule, meet at the, uh,
the jerk JP side and assistant production,
who I send mails and we are doing, uh,
the meeting for the sequence I have choose. At first,
the day you send me a storyboard,
a storyboard is a little comic technical.
Camika about a rough.
Outline of the.
Weeds are coming, our walks a technical notes. Right. And I choose my sequence.
A sequence can be just like three Curt certificates,
19 cats. What, what, what's a cart cut.
Like one scene, like one continuous scene below. I see the scene changes. So,
you know, when in live action, when you film something and then the camera cuts,
obviously in animation that you don't have an entire scene that you cut out of
that's preplanned. Right. Right. That makes sense. Okay.
And so one chin can be one second or 10,
second 30 seconds is depends. Right. And if there is a lot of seconds,
it's more walks ride. Right. Naturally. And so like, Alexa,
take an example. Okay. We choose district once it's 10 kids.
And so I go to the meeting, so reaching for,
with the director and he going to explain me how he see,
uh, how he wants those 10 cuts make. Okay. Right. And he spanked me.
Yeah. For this skirt, I would like a rough animation,
a more action, like a form of West coast, or we'll set, uh.
Soccer, soccer goes like the Western slang word for like,
so the word soccer in Western world is.
Completely different to what soccer in Japanese actually is. Yeah. So in,
so in the anime community, we refer to soccer as good animation. Right?
Lots of frames, lots of flashy animation,
but in Japanese soccer guard just means frames. You.
Look into Kanji, Sacco, make.
Picture. Yeah. So it's kind of become like a buzz word. Yeah.
Right. Right. Makes sense. If you say anime in Japan
and your mission, but if you say any man in a.
West, it's just the Japanese.
Japanese on it. So in Japan, monsters Inc. Is technically an animal.
Yes. I love my enemy list. Hello. Hello.
Wait. So you had like 10 cuts on my hero. Academia.
Yeah. And different types of animation.
Uh, different types of animations. Sometimes just the talkings. Yeah.
Little actings and sometimes some, uh, action kits.
And so I do the, the meeting with the director, so it takes like 30 minutes,
uh, of the, so I have to do the first step. It's the layout. Yeah.
So I'm going to.
You're telling me words and I have no idea what the layout is. Uh.
I see you in one scene and I have to draw
the background with the character on it and,
or the movement of the character, just rough, very rough. They were rough.
And also if there is a Camero walks, I have to add it. Right. And,
uh, all of put the timing of this kits.
Oh, wow. Okay. So it's basically like, it's, it's basically like the storyboard,
but just a bit more.
We're fine. We're fine. It's fine.
She, a character, what movement he will do, just.
Like when you see like there's outlines, sketches.
Like that.
And that's it. You don't need to push it to the most.
So you have to watch your drawings of it.
You have to know a bit or the, what the character is armor or clot.
Exactly. And when you finished that, you saw it,
you send it back to the director. [inaudible] will check it, uh,
at some, uh, corruption. All the armies are true, low,
more higher expression, not sad, more angry. Uh,
and after those correction, by the director, it's we go to the second.
So, uh, [inaudible] animation director. Okay. Okay.
And the animation director, we put it at your drawings more in model.
So if you have C good drawing,
it's because of the SAC can have putter or his get on it because the second in
one episodes there is at least one or two and he,
they have to check the 150 cuts.
Oh, wow. So,
so they basically make sure that the characters kind of look the same and
consistent throughout in fact, uh, the.
Animators just to draw a rough diamond.
And if this diamond is good, Cory T after the second can Polish it.
Right.
So like how many, like, say for like my hero academia,
like an episode of my hair, academia,
like how many different animators would be working on like one episode,
for instance, like individual animals seem, uh, on average.
An average, uh, uh, at least 10 nanometers. It would be good if you bet, uh,
you can see on the credit, right? How many animators Ganga into Potkin gap,
right? Uh, how many is that?
You made some time you have the 1500 meters or sometime you have
what is called one man army.
Just one guy, one guy. Wow. Never done that. Oh, no, no,
no, actually I'm just a baby man.
I was going to say like.
You have to be to do the Savio of an entire 24 minute episode. Yeah.
Yeah. And the dusk guys are core monsters.
Yeah. Just like red light. Just destroy the risks like this
very fast.
You see,
this is a Japanese animation when you see a veteran animator. Okay.
Yeah, sure. You mentioned one guy doing it all.
Like it's like that scene from Hunter, Hunter,
where the guy returns from like being up in the mountains for like 10 years or
something.
Just returns.
Everyone has done. And everyone becomes his disciples.
They me like one day you can do it in one.
Some people have too much talent. Right.
Also. I mean, I'm just, uh, I'm sorry. Two, one. Yeah. Right. And the guy,
my senpai is like 31 years of experience in animation,
right?
No, that's what Jim said, baby.
Five years in the anime industry is like nothing. It's nothing. Wow. Oh my God.
Well, we'll have, we'll have you back on in 20 years.